over watches voice actors are just as  important as the characters they play  and Terry Crews wants in I'm Tony and I  fully support this GameSpot news update  doom fist is a character mentioned a few  times in overwatch and he's rumored to  be the next playable hero Terry Crews  has tweeted out his desire to play doom  fist and now the rock is voicing his  support with a tweet of his own the  former wrestler might not even be  familiar with the game but hey having  the rock on your side can't hurt Terry  Crews even got to visit blizzards studio  recently which is only making the rumor  mill spin faster we'll see what happens  doom fist would be the third new  character to come to overwatch after  both Anna and Sombra released in 2016 so  do you want to hear Terry Crews in the  game do you have another voice actor in  mind let me know in the comments or on  twitter at chaingun poke and for all the  latest on overwatch you're already in  the right place  you